eu lembro comer uma refeição em casa
enquanto criança
o piloto era sempre o mesmo vi a matança
do animal ganhe a cabo os cabos datas e
outra pessoa cozinhava rosnam taxa no
prato estes três elementos entre lavos
jorge outros proveitos com alguns tal
este sempre em segundo plano já que
dizia que o hospital não chamava que a
nossa
essa seqüência de eventos prolongada ao
longo da semana
e essas belas morenas dos anos 90
procuraram a refeição também apenas os
rituais mudaram de repente deixamos
cyberlynxx à porta de casa
os animais já não era dos campeonatos
nenhum em coleta de plástico as batatas
começaram a receber cada vez mais a
relação àquela que havia sido uma
refeição tão aprimorada deu lugar a
conveniência da minha família
alimentava-se da mesma forma a nossa
nutrição na mesma
eu sei que a minha geração não devia ter
tido esta tipo memórias lá fora onde
dizia que o consumismo é o caminho do
futuro ou inclusive até uma altura em
que carlos tão exóticos como avestruz
o crocodilo é um cenário habitual nos
dois frigoríficos e os supermercados
esta era a europa do qual todos tínhamos
anunciado simples tornando assim sem
mais nem menos
num país de direito depois vieram as
crises sucessivas o país em shows e
nuvens de fumo
as pessoas começaram a prender um
próprio vídeo no papel e as nossas
opções de alimentação foram se tornando
tendencialmente mais baratas proibição
do estudo continuamos a aumentar em
grande escala daquela que é o elemento
mais valorizado nas nossas refeições e
será que esta forma de nos alimentarmos
é um dependente de proteína uma forma de
mascarar jackman mas a posição social
sofrível
irritada ou será que esse comportamento
massa um espelho é da nossa perda de
identidade e tradição gastronômica pela
qual temos todos tanto carinho
o flaming um caso no ano passado com
deixou perplexo
enquanto percorriam os olhos de um
supermercado de para mim é observar um
saque frangos cinco frangos cinco anos
é isso não era uma promoção por questões
de calendário não era um produto com um
alvo muito específico na sociedade um
consumidor ou imprecisos ou em regime de
poupança que desprovido daquelas
pequenas cadeias alimentares que outrora
fizeram da nossa gastronomia um final
tão expansiva que inclusive deixou
pegadas em continente estão distantes
como as américas
o ásia este francos só somou hoje uma
imagem da gastronomia o melhor daquilo
que nós comemos província do bié
insípido paulo classic para isso não é
um problema exclusivo de portugal existe
um pouco todo mundo porém a exemplos
bons fora que podemos agora é absorver
uma forma de tentar resolver um problema
pra mim é dos problemas mais prementes
do hoje em dia que é a questão da nossa
soberania alimentar
o que é isto a soberania alimentar
ora segundo jambô daiko parece política
soberania ou entender soberania entidade
que não é assim é superior na ordem
externa nem igual na ordem interna ou
seja soberania alimentar crescer a nossa
reivindicação individual e coletiva
daquilo que nós realmente queremos comer
e não aquilo que já enviava passada pela
indústria a aumentar
aliás o próprio nome indústria alimentar
não só vai parar quando penso indústria
lembra
sei lá eu não fumo pesquisados águas
poluídas e que tem a ver com vida
infelizmente essa indústria hoje tem um
largo no pólo
aquilo que nós comemos inclusive veio
essa indústria explore exaustivamente
apenas quatro cinco variedades de
plantas milho soja palma arroz
o próprio coco é que aliada com a
produção intensiva de carnes houve
animais representa cerca de 80% de toda
a área agrícola do planeta seja nós
quando vamos comemos kinder goianos o
coca cola soube max ou então vamos um
estranho criminoso
inicialmente a primeira mesma coisa e
esta perca diversidade que é o
verdadeiro inimigo que esta perca em
livro cidade dos nossos pratos
representa uma perda de precisar dos
campos de cultivo e isso resulta em uma
redução drástica da nossa capacidade em
lidar com problemas com epidemias
alterações climáticas e para casa ter
conhecido com o súbito aumento da
intolerância alimentar o que nós podemos
fazer para resolver este problema da
nossa soberania alimentar que nós
podemos fazer para ajudar reivindicar os
nossos direitos de escolher aquilo que
realmente queremos comer um dos exemplos
lá fora eo passeio vários anos na
dinamarca onde há cinco anos a marca é
um país que não tem historicamente um
lugar de gastronomia praticamente zero
o país produz tanques cirurgia
essencialmente de todo durante vários
anos que as pessoas não eram permitidas
a ter prazer em comer tanto aquilo que
nós estamos habituados aquelas noites
convívio estrutura e aceitarmos a mesa
vemos vinho riso tudo isso não existia
muita madeira marca hoje em dia um
distingue uma referência gastronômica
que inclusivamente até mais reconhecido
que o nosso próprio país
ora isso aconteceu essa transformação
aconteceu mais ou menos de uma década
atrás
evoluí um final muito interessantes
entre dois fatores da sociedade entre
restaurantes que o público seja o
restaurante repente lembraram sejam
daqui um sentimento
há de tudo o que o que é combustível ou
tudo aquilo de certa forma a presença
representa a nossa área geográfica é e
então foram à procura de coisas tão
longínquo hoje e dos pratos deus que
carambola provas amarelas salvagem vice
chico formiga e até o próprio público
teve curiosidade seguiu esse fenômeno
que partiriam uma troca de idéias 23 que
fomentou a uma vontade de explorar
aquela área geográfica é muito
específica da escandinávia através do
próprio folato deus olha aqui o que põe
pra cá portugal é uma coisa geralmente
frente mas eu tento criar e estimular o
máximo possível diversidade nos nossos
pratos novos campos por exemplo está no
topo cultivar 46 variedade de tomate
hora sempre muito vocês formam no final
36 vagas 4 mas pensamos que existem mais
550 variedade de tomate no mundo inteiro
a razão é que começou duas outras
variedades tomada durante o ano todo mas
é uma das que são cultivados durante
todo o ano
estufas são colhidas quando estão em
viaturas estavam essencialmente cartão
quando amy uso e os tomates não eram
assim e quando era pequeno os tomates do
mercado eram tão tão mais duros que os
senhores não nos deixar muito cara
criancinhas não chega não chega perto
não pisavam tomado na hora estes
formatos diferentes cores e feitios
transportavam no meu imaginário para um
lugar onde eu não a vi estava nos sentir
que é um familiar e assim é uma coisa
que estava preservado para as próximas
gerações
esse mesmo imaginar essa capacidade de
chá deixarmos guiar pelas nossas
sensações angus tentativas pelo ato o
sensorial é transportar nos para outros
lugares do imaginário e portugal querem
fazer cá em portugal
quem nos pode ajudar a concretizar este
desejo
nós temos um clima fantástico não é
todos nós que estamos no nosso clima já
disse nicolau breyner que antes pobre
mas flui em portugal do rico
o prémio em estocolmo a mais 2800 horas
de sol por ano
temperaturas médias acima de 15 graus
centígrados nós conseguimos resolver
duas questões essenciais à prática da
agricultura que são água e fertilidade
dos solos
temos condições únicas de magníficas
bater uma prática agrícola nutritiva e
diversa
depois temos uma longa tradição
gastronômica
mas pergunto já agora onde é que não
haja vacinas disse que até cursos o que
será da sopa seca da minha mãe se mais
ninguém como costumamos dizer que somos
um povo nostálgico
gostamos de viver da memória mas que
mora estaremos nós daqui a algumas
décadas não agirmos agora numa ação
coletiva e individual para preservar a
nossa tradição gastronômica inclusive
expandi-lo para isso aí que isso é muita
informação e mas gostava de vos
perguntar uma coisa
será que nós hoje conseguimos aqui
conseguimos agir individualmente e
coletivamente uma forma para nos
alimentarmos melhor com mais intensidade
com mais segmento inclusive com mais
respeito pelos nossos próprios corpos
eu acho que sim porque como todos nós
temos uma refeição em boa companhia
sabe sempre melhor